uh you know having worked with
ecosystems like
um you know paris milano lisbon
south africa or cape town in particular
right
um many of those ecosystems are looking
at israel as a model and try to
replicate that
you know i think all of them you know
without any well say you know this thing
probably they're looking to
be the next startup nation right welcome
to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel at stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
being joined by raz bachar global lead
for startup emerging technologies
and managing director of israel at
microsoft for startups
he is a business development
professional and strategist in
generating growth for tech services and
products
before microsoft rus built and drove the
growth for aws across several startup
ecosystems in europe
middle east and africa through strategic
planning community building
and partnerships with vcs and
accelerators
how are you thank you for joining me i'm
doing well my quizlet how are you
i'm i'm doing great you have such an
in an incredible history within the
startup ecosystem
uh and you've gone with you've worked
with
with incredible companies like aws where
you were head of startup business
development of
emea and now most recently managing
director of microsoft's
global industry lead at microsoft
startup for startups microsoft for
startups
and i'm excited to to hear about you
know your experience working with the
startup ecosystem as an incubator
from a corporate but but also as a
mentor for startups and watching them
grow and
and how you even got to be a mentor for
startup incubation because that you know
if i follow the trend of what you did
before that's not trivial thing to
to get to so share with me a little bit
about your own journey and and how you
got into this world
sure so happy to again again thank you
for having me i will say that again
basically like i haven't planned
anything you know from career
perspective
but uh i'm an engineering background i
had my own like
cloud integration company before you
know cloud was a thing
i ended up shutting this down joined the
hp for a little while
basically at that point you know it kind
of got discovered
all of the a sales
world you know doing a roll of a
piece of storage and then you know i
kind of relocate from israel to
luxembourg
to a basically like to kickstart edibles
operation in
in israel for the first time uh the nice
though is that i don't have like
every single cio in israel basically
threw me out you know from the room
trying to explain to them you know what
is cloud computing back then in 2011
so um you know it was it was a crazy
period basically just evangelizing cloud
computing
uh after amazon and networks opened the
offices back in 2014 if i was taking
i stayed back then i saw a great
opportunity kind of you know
working with startups which is again
what i love
more than anything else right and they
end up opening like a new operation
which was the
uh startup business development team for
uh for aws and they
led that across europe middle east
africa and
i think the fascinating thing uh that
that role kind of taught me is the fact
that
you know we always can't consider
ourselves know the startup nation and we
sometimes know
tend to uh overuse that phrase
but you know having work with ecosystems
like
um you know paris milano lisbon
south africa or cape town in particular
right
um many of those ecosystems you know are
looking at israel as a model and try to
replicate that
uh you know i think all of them you know
without any well say you know this thing
probably they're looking to
be the next startup nation right uh
each one you know kind of try to
fine-tune their
unique properties and offering to to
their
audience their existence to their to the
developers their investors
but you know it's fascinating to see how
much respect
and appreciation there is towards the
user ecosystem um
following that you know i can't really
look at it back wait whereas i have to
stop you on that note because i think
it's interesting sure you're talking
about the respect that other countries
are perhaps giving to the startup nation
you know i think this is something
that's actually really
uh you know something to to dwell on for
a second because you've gotten to
experience the startup incubation across
uh the middle east uh europe and eastern
africa you mentioned correct
yeah and so tell me a little bit more
about this
startup nation as a model and what
you've been what do you learn from
watching startups grow in these
different ecosystems and how perhaps
you know things that we may be taking
for granted here in the startup nation
that
that you've come to realize that it's
actually pretty quite special
so i will say that again like
these are kind of things that we already
got used to right but in the end like
when you look at things like
uh what happened in in portugal or
lisbon particular right so
it was kind of the perfect storm the
fact that you know we had
um engineers which are relatively
you know uh affordable right
they were in the same thousand in the
same time zone in the as the
as the uk and relatively close to new
york or to the
uh even you know the uh the west coast
right
um more and more like
the government money government programs
actually made like more
attractive for investors to to invest in
in those kind of
like in the specific ecosystem in
parallel to that there were incentives
for researchers
to you know basically take their ip that
they created and you know
develop it to something and then uh the
nice thing is that like all of those
components were you know
were incubated separately until they
were you know a couple of accelerators
and
that was the most amazing thing which
you know we didn't experience that in
israel because
in israel we had the uzma initiative you
know by the government was kind of
forced top down to some extent right
but over there you saw how it started
from the field and you know basically
being propped from
you know the cliche sentence of
community managers
right just grouping together to create
this conception and
just bringing to the table you know the
government representative the academy
the investors the uh
student union the student university is
right and
you know having spent that wheel for
a couple of months or even a couple of
years just doing it
in the most spontaneous way that you
could imagine
uh suddenly you saw startups like you
know
unbubble or um
well forget the name of the luxury brand
i it will come to me in a second
but like there were a couple of really
really you know high potential startups
that were you know started there and
grew eventually
richie come to unicorn status exit and
now
uh because of that exit like few other
stuff has been created and
and then you know on top of all of that
a
web summit which was kind of you know
the the
the black swan like in a positive way
right that suddenly
had to shift location and got shift from
ireland to
uh to portugal suddenly made like it
rose that ecosystem to the
like to the world stage right and
i i will say that you know in israel we
tend to speak a lot about tel aviv right
that's kind of the
the first place but they i definitely
think that you know the
the group and organization from made in
jerusalem for example this is like the
exact same model that i'm seeing
you know kind of being built to
incubate and to grow new ecosystems all
across those regions
so incubating new monologue that that
was awesome
incubating new ecosystems incubating new
startups talk to me a little bit about
what you're doing today with with
microsoft
and the transition from aws and how do
you
envision microsoft for startups program
perfect so within microsoft for startups
like we're covering you know startups
all across their
lifecycle from the two developers in the
garage to the unicorns in the world
working with
all the existing partners like you know
accelerators vcs
a staff organization like the expert
institutes or
uh or stop nation central right so all
of those
organizations now we have obviously no
different
offerings and programs to different
startups in different stages
even you know three individual
developers or entrepreneurs
i will say that probably like the best
value position that we have
is to connect startups with uh
either you know our ecosystem partners
right so we're actually doing like deal
flow
sharing with uh with the investors and
exercises that we're working with
the other one is the fact that they were
trying to connect them to
the microsoft customers and we have
dedicated programs
to do that at scale and efficiently and
then the last thing and again this is
something that's been like
a an amazing experience like you know to
see um
those you know many successes over time
is connecting startups with uh with the
product groups right
which again some of the most difficult
thing for early stage startup is you
know
they especially as they get started they
suddenly come and say you know
i'm going to sell to you know to the
biggest bank in the world the biggest
insurance organization in the world
right and
like 99.9 percent of the times they are
you know way over their head and they
eventually know they're getting this
money
and i am saying you know more uh
you know of those pocs and you know an
extreme level
of openness from the product groups and
from the business development manager
and from you know other functions in the
organization like even if you look at
you know legal and finance and you know
hr
right like all of them are excited about
you know working with startups and
supporting entrepreneurs whether it be
as
giving them you know the insight that
they have because again these are people
that's been in industry for a long time
and obviously you know they're kind of
at the the front end of some of the most
complex organizations that there is
right and you know either they share
their knowledge as
mentors as experts or they even give
them
a you know ability to integrate to some
extent to their product groups right if
it makes any sense of course and so can
can you give me some examples of how
you know you've been working with
startups and how they're actually
getting integrated into the microsoft
ecosystem
through this program and it sounds like
a lot of this is based on also
a lot of trust and a relationship that
is building over time it's not just here
to get credit for
microsoft azure it's much more about
okay here's you know get integrated into
into our ecosystem and we can bring our
knowledge and expertise into working
with these multinationals
to help you bring your product to
fruition right
right so i'll say two things right like
one of them is that they i'll actually
leverage the opportunity to to mention
about
another activity that we have which is
kind of the max of accelerator which
you know kind of its new brand which is
the ai for good
that one it's an accelerator for real
estate startup
you know powered by ai with
impact oriented solutions and the last
year we actually won you know the best
excellent of uh
uh a award in israel right so again it
was
a humbling experience i'd say to get the
recognition for that category not no
for the regular impact category so you
know i think that that says a lot
um and just give an example from from
that program right so we had
a last year a company named right here
right and they have a solution that or
even you know pecan that
introduce us uh but last year we had a
startup called the right here and they
have
a indoor navigation system for people
with a blind imperative
and you know beyond the part of the
acceleration program again kind of with
the mentoring the coaching on the
business side
we supported them on the takeoff side
you know they're just leveraging the
technology
and the and the
microsoft tech resources
beyond that again like we've made a lot
of uh
effort on the joint go to market
activities and i think like the
the the chair at the top was the fact
that uh we love those solutions so much
that we actually you know brought them
internally into microsoft and microsoft
actually became their customer
ending up with having their solution
kind of deployed you know in the
microsoft campus in tel aviv and uh
right and that's kind of a win-win-win
situation because you know
basically they get like another customer
and a great brand
uh we get to support our startups and
you know either our
employees with that relevant uh
disability or
you know visitors to the campus get to
have you know an amazing experience
right
so i think you know this is like a huge
example the other thing that they'll
that they'll add up is that and again
this is
some it's some education that we still
need to do for the
for the for the for the exercise because
of some of the
history that we have is that we're not
only you know kind of representing azure
right so obviously no it's a very
well-known brand again as a technology
company
it makes sense it will represent kind of
the cloud offering but we also look at
the other suite of solutions that
microsoft have right so if you look at
linkedin github xbox office 365
right so and the list is uh the list is
longer
and again two trillion dollar company i
believe uh
as of today or yesterday exactly and um
i will say that again kind of in this in
the second
half that they have around kind of
working in the
course industry vertical you know i've
been exposed to
you know the microsoft biology
department and the robotics and the
space division
right and these are like amazing uh
projects that microsoft is taking part
of which is
you know going to privatize in the way
that we
that we uh we have in our daily life
right
amazing and so you know the whole
ecosystem today
is you know it's very competitive not
just competitive uh
between startups but also between
venture capital investors and i'm sure
that also within you know accelerators
and and such programs
that are looking to get in to get you
know a strong relationship with the
startups
you know early on so that they can uh
work continue work with them as they
progress
how do you experience this you know
cooperation
right now within the ecosystem and and
how do you how do you see the balance
shifting in the last
few years so overall you know
the more help startup can get the the
better
right like it's just like increasing the
buy i think that certainly it is
these days now we see we see more
supports
aka funding and talent being a
kind of you know
absolutely like getting sucked you know
to the
to the unicorns of the world to the to
the
large scale company the charging ponies
right like that's
you know the trending name uh and
as part of that i will say that no early
state startups and early and first-time
founders
probably need as much help as they can
get
now more than ever uh and again
any help that we can get or you know
even like cross-collaboration with
with other vendors this is something
that we see as
a as a blast because again in the end
like it comes down to
meeting the people getting to know them
and as you mentioned before like
building that rafter relationship is
more important than
anything else again because as they're
getting started they're not kind of
you know they're not generating any uh
significant
workloads right it's something that will
come
later on but they definitely think that
the value and the relationship and the
trust that you build is something that
can
uh sustained for a very long time
amazing and so your day-to-day as you're
working with all these different
startups
and you're moving where where do you fit
into this right so
you know as the managing director of
this program and thinking through these
accelerators in this part of the
ecosystem
how does your day today actually look
like er
well i'm i'm lucky enough that
every day is different right especially
like kind of in a in a
covered or in a hybrid kind of model
that that we're in
i will say that again i'm splitting my
time between you know
obviously getting to like
having just to meet as many founders as
possible like on average i'm seeing
between 800 to 1000
startups per year right which is uh
which is enough uh again to get a
perspective
but but also you know this is what i
mean i enjoy doing
and the other part is again kind of
working through some of the operational
uh heavy lifting that we have kind of
running the programs that
that we have and then the the last part
is you know obviously microsoft is a
huge organization
and for better for us you know we need
to
manage the internal resources the
expectations
the internal stakeholders and this is
also something that uh
that needs to be done uh mo more often
then i then i expect i find you know how
these things kind of coordinate together
because
again when i invest in learning in like
learning more about the organization
finding about a new product group and
suddenly i remember you know
i started i met couple of months ago
that can have a great
fit to death specifically that they
raised because of meeting
now that's another kind of win-win
situation that we can generate right so
amazing just amazing thank you so much
for coming here
i really appreciate it i have i have a
few more questions before i let you go
and i want to take you back to your
childhood and i want to ask you what
really fascinated you as a kid
whether it's a subject in school or a
passion hobby
what was it uh
i honestly i think just
spending time outside the house as much
as possible just being in nature
working uh traveling like that's the
thing that i enjoy the most right
very cool and an inspiration today
something that in the day to day
inspires you whether it's
something that's happening some person
that is living
yeah so over here sorry for the chance
but but my kids
right so again i have like a
four-year-old daughter and
three-year-old son
and again obviously you know since they
came to the world they
definitely saw kind of a shift on
uh moving away with just kind of the
slogan of you know
working to make the world a better place
to actually try to be a little bit more
uh
purposeful with regards to you know how
and well
i invest my time and you know it's
hardly a
let's say it makes me a little bit more
biased towards startups that i
enjoy helping more than others so
i will say with that all right and
three words you would use to describe
yourself
uh i'll use a
a sentence for that but it's two three
words so it's a leap of faith
i definitely think that again many times
in uh in the business that we're in
um you know there's only
as much that we can learn data that we
can look at
and the due diligence that we can do
in the end you know we need to take the
leap of faith in order to
make sure that the person on the other
end you know can deliver on the
whatever it is that they're doing or you
know
even if it's something you know informal
that you agree on you know you need to
take the leap of faith for
them to uh to meet their promise or
anything like that
right and especially when you're working
with the
early stage founders when you invest
resources necessary time so
so yeah
with microsoft for startups continuing
to make it what sounds like an
incredible incredible program and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you
dude thank you so much